I'm all set it's 12:40 and they go well
ladies and gentlemen we're out on a
little trouble with the tail little
sensor on the tail okay oh my god yeah
that's cool reality we're gonna get out
there and fix it oh we can't get up
there right now cuz the wind the wind so
I'm like what then the guy goes I got a
new plane in here oh that's cool how
long well six fifteen twelve fourteen
Appaloosa get in take a seat for the
next five hours
oh alright then he'll go for a hike man
I can't do that so do that and then I'm
waiting getting on my plane planting
land in five minutes ladies and
gentleman circling the airport
oh well it's circling there's nothing I
get this I literally want to jump I get
this I'm like I can't wait to get
[ __ ] home come on because I want to
see my kids too you know and I get this
I get well I spoke too soon ladies and
gentlemen unfortunately the winds are
not allowed on the plane to land and it
is turning back and going to Salt Lake
City so no but she's what I died yeah
nobody was good you literally just want
to like I'll put you on a middle seat on
United at 9:30 in the next morning if
you'd like oh is that the best you can
do that so you literally wanna die
so um there is a website called herp
alert and balloons yes people can
actually send in photos of what they
think may be herpes and there is a
doctor who runs the site who will then
tell you like oh this probably is herpes
or my doctor not college kid but yeah
maybe but they've noticed that there was
a huge spike on their website within the
two weeks Coachella was happening
usually they get about twenty photos per
day while Coachella was happening they
got 250 photos each and every day cream
which came out to eleven hundred and
five different cases that they diagnosed
yeah those kids are [ __ ] it man get
the [ __ ] you like why else would you go
to the desert listen to music yeah
exactly
I like how everyone's hey you know I
actually looks really fun you want to
have sex inside a van without a beam
inside a tent in the desert yeah in a
tent well you hear people all around you
what's wrong what's the other thing they
do up north in the desert Burning Man
yes you catch it aids at Burning Man hey
catch a lot of things well it's just
herpes don't be so don't you take a pill
yeah take a pill for the rest of your
life screw that's probably the best can
see well no for the midea spread the
best oh yeah I take a shower hold it
forever yeah no they've had it yeah but
people have had I mean apparently you've
been exposed to herpes and whether or
not you get it or not depends on your
genetics but some people get another
mouth yep that's a meter section in your
mouth you have a better chance of not
getting it on your genitals because you
have an inherent immunity to it either
way not good my cousin you wanna hang
out with a girl with Claire with
chlamydia and they used to call her
Claire midea and when she walks in the
room they used to just give her a round
of applause well she had a lot maybe you
just take did she take a pill or
something or a shot yeah poor girl yeah
poor girl but then again like you like
that drippy she's like no all the homies
you know I felt like the homies had it
to a lot of guy a lot of people have it
they don't know it you're good chlamydia
and gonorrhea can be asymptomatic mm-hmm
so and a lot of wait a minutes a problem
cuz you can go yeah a lot of men don't
know that they have it yeah well I told
you I talked to my friend I'm like
you've never used a condom Manama it's
just he was short with just spikes I was
like dude that girl is like crazy now oh
my god I was like any guy could geez
economy was an Allen T that should I
never want to kind of my own
I know but dude she's a she's [ __ ] on
film a lot now listen it's fine but you
just need to he goes uh you know he has
I'll say later he goes I I never had
that I he goes I mean my I've had to my
dick is tripped before but nothing you
know I know
that's called chlamydia or carrying a
[ __ ] dummy yeah can you do dude
take a pill take four pills at the same
time i McGregor oh I was 1 billion for
his proper whiskey and it out it
actually beat Jameson hey um
now let me ask them you think he owns
10% right more yeah
buy more yeah I never do well but I
didn't know I was gonna be this good I
thought I'd do that but I thought it
would do exceptionally well that's
amazing so Pete yeah people I go he
should fight man okay yeah yeah it's
gonna be tough for him why would you
fight he said that it's in his blood
that he had like as a fighter he has to
have that still you think y'all fight
again
and I'll see what I don't see what the
ups and I probably well yeah because
he's me board there's so much money's
gonna be aboard any the opportunities
gonna be there and then your season
gonna hey will paid this much alright
yeah be fun to go through camp and get
the fans going again specially and get a
win mm-hmm I bet fights again yeah I
really think see absolutely not if I was
him but that's why I mean that's what
it's him well yet you still be doing a
lot of stuff though right if you were a
billionaire right now or would you just
want to lay back and not do anything
nothing would change I'd have more car
that's it I'd live in the same house no
I show the wanted you stand up there's
nothing like stayin out do my podcast I
couldn't I like doing this I don't I
don't do any of this for money I don't
need to do stand-up I make enough money
doing this I don't have to do stand-up I
just stand because I love it I'll have
to do other shows i doing because I want
to
there you go another thing that'll
change to be traveling it flying I'd
have more cars that's it
and not have an assistant that you'd
have to talk to to get to me what yeah
what it's like you'd ask me a question
cap that I never get to me you get in
that Ferrari talk to my assistant [ __ ]
man let me know okay objectify you know
I was watching the other day in the
hotel room my brother and I were it was
in Phoenix turn shows we're in the hotel
room we're watching a Total Recall Total
Recall Slager
great movie there's no way you can make
it to don't really like that oh wait cuz
we don'twe when he's in the machine he
hits that pic it's fantasy they're all
do you like athletic curvy skinny he's
all athletic and then they're all and
then they're all turk lassie or sleazies
up sleazy and it's like going through
the girl and her tits and our ass damn
we're never weird science we're weird
science they're building yeah you know
it's funny about that that's gonna
happen it's already happening with like
dolls and simulation you choose what you
want you can do it with porn there they
have all these they're gonna they're
gonna customize that you can build a
ship it's like a look like an Android so
it may be politically incorrect but I
guarantee that's on its way I just I
want you know one of the you know it's
bothered it's like are we now going to
start Nate are we now going to censor
our past
of course historically going to are we
gonna mmm it's like I heard there was
there's a museum in Swift and they were
literally changing the names of it was
it was something like little n boy which
is I get it right but this is 300 years
ago dancing to little dark poignant like
like you are we gonna revise it to the
point where cool aliens years from like
thousand years ago while these people
really progressed they really were
progressively really were ahead of it
look what they did
I feel like goddamn it you can't like
I'm not saying listen I understand what
the Civil War monuments right the
Buffalo Bills don't have monuments built
to them because they lost [ __ ] four
Super Bowls okay you lost what are the
museum give it context that's that
there's not like you know there's
nothing you know Marv levy [ __ ]
statue Buffalo because Marv loss yeah
robert e lee lost he got a gopro you
know build statues to that he was also
fighting but actually in the place
exactly and get it back I'd be like I'd
have a bit funky [ __ ] statue I got out
of here but you know you do put in a
museum I don't care rednecks wanna give
it some context say this is what this
guy did cuz this is what happened rights
still history so it's our history it's
ugly it's uncomfortable it's awkward but
don't erase it don't erase it yeah
that's lads now that's more dangerous
it's important to know one you know what
happened yeah important to know that's
exactly about even onset now would you
be like whenever like I was at the where
was I last I was at The Improv last
night doing a set and there's a female
come before me I just gave her a high
five like I don't hug you I don't
because I'm worried about I'm sure on
set it's different yeah before all this
I'm sure you know girl yeah Ramona got
put an hour ago I don't do it it's also
extremely I'm not controlling this [ __ ]
they are promised that they get into PR
they get into a human resources
departments at big corporations yeah
because they study Gender Studies and
they have nothing else to do but be
resentful activists so now they get in
there and they cause all these [ __ ]
speech codes and all kinds of stuff
they're basically tyrannical you know
who's the first person I saw that he saw
this movement coming off see had his
history with hit the maid at his house
Arnold Schwarzenegger I went to event he
was at and there's all these people
taking pictures with him but he wouldn't
take a picture with just a girl so if
just a girl came up if I do you you
better have a friend or male friend and
he really oh yeah about eight with just
one girl right like you might leave here
then this say oh this is where I met him
was just me and him alone and you don't
have another no matter what I think I
see fries like this why see do they so
prior to run whoa dude this is 10 years
ago like what's so Perry cuz he ran it
hard oh man Harvey two in the paint
still for 70 that looked like a roll
also that Guatemala kid that were like
it looks like him as a Guatemalan like
yes that kid is not who's on Howard
Stern is like worst it was still trying
to figure it out like where you know I
made mistakes and like he's like you
know me and the family and the kids and
then what's the kid's name I fur
because even him we're all together as a
family I said I got to me it's like a
Samba had like dinner with them and I go
and I kind of do with jokingly said
we're talking about women our daughters
and I go well I just don't want my
daughter dating a guy like me and he
goes that's right he
it's so weird cuz the rest of his kids
don't look like him at all so for this
one yeah right
look dude come on do it do it you could
do it I'm doing that's awesome man
though that's awesome but here's the
thing I always forget his four seven
eight always forgiven by the way cuz you
know what Schwarzenegger went yeah I
mean what he gonna do when he got the
showers like come on do it do it I know
a hot makeup artist he was fifty at the
time when I was talking to her I
remember it being like you're so hot and
and she said she was Tim she was no I
she was a wardrobe and she was doing his
wardrobe in his house in his closet and
he just started making out with her and
I said did you he goes she goes I did I
did because it's one Arnold and he's hot
and what am I gonna do I was like thank
you for but so Arnold just he's I you
know to especially when he's young you
walk in a room it's like her star let's
look at pumping iron like like you tell
those stories from pumping iron it's
like it's odd to that's the way it went
that I invented and again it's like it's
like him here's the thing if everybody's
if everybody's if everybody's obliged
and everybody's consenting and
everybody's like it's like then but it
doesn't matter because he was such a
stud he was a cyst called living brother
his face